- Were you left though
with any battle wounds
from your football days?
Cause I grew up in Texas
and like, it didn't matter.
If you came out a boy you
were playing football.
Like if you wanted to or not.
like, I had a lot of guy
friends than had to play
and they get so injured.
So like, I mean, do
you have a lot of them?
- Well, you know I'm a Texas boy too.
That's where I'm originally from and yeah,
I mean I've had, you know, pec surgery,
wrist surgery, all these different things.
I feel great now, but you know my fingers,
see how my fingers are like crooked.
They don't go together.
- [Kelly] Oh, yep yep.
- See this pinky, see that?
And how about, how about this one?
Okay, and how about this one?
- Oh my God!
Oh my God, don't do it, don't do it.
Don't do it, I can't believe you did it.
Oh, you're like those
double jointed people.
- No, that is what you
call tearing the ligaments
to your finger and that
is what you're left with.
But I've had thumb
surgeries and all that stuff
and I won't do it again but yeah,
it's like a good party trick.
- Oh my God, please say you did
that like on your first date
like when you're ready,
just like check this out.
That awesome.
- That way you know she's a keeper
if she sticks around after that.
- Like he's weird, I'm down.